Republicans are distancing themselves
from gambling mogul Steve Wynn after a
report of sexual misconduct he is no
longer GOP finance chairman after a Wall
Street Journal story that Wynn demanded
naked massages and sex acts from current
and former employees Speaker Paul Ryan
and other House Republicans say they'll
donate wins contributions to charity
bianna golodryga is here with more on
the political fallout when you could say
that even Sin City has its limitations
for what's acceptable right Steve Wynn's
name is synonymous with the Las Vegas
Strip and he has been a fixture at the
White House dining there five times with
the president he's also helped the
Republican Party amass a record jackpot
in fundraiser these recent allegations
have party leaders panicking about past
and future donations from their star
funder and another great friend of mine
stand up Steve a longtime friend of
President Trump Steve Wynn found a new
role with the GOP after the campaign
Steve your job is raising money for the
Republican Party on CBS this morning he
was asked about his turn from Las Vegas
to Washington this administration has
has turned the attitude of America into
a can-do attitude the casino mogul is
calling the accusations against him
preposterous but on Saturday he stepped
down as RNC finance chair over the last
five years Wynn has donated more than
one and a half million dollars to the
Republican Party and candidates the RNC
has not returned any of his
contributions despite last year
repeatedly calling Harvey Weinstein's
donations to the DNC dirty money even
GOP leaders called on the party to give
back wins contributions I don't even
think it's a close call to return at the
money before backing Trump when also
donated to Hillary Clinton's 2016
presidential campaign Clinton is also
facing heat for her handling of sexual
misconduct allegations against a senior
adviser on her 2008 bid for president
the New York Times reported that Clinton
was made aware of the accusations but
allowed him to stay on over the weekend
Clinton said at the time the allegation
had been quote taken seriously and
address
all of this comes as Republican Florida
Senator Marco Rubio who has received
donations from Steve Wynn announced the
firing of his chief of staff after
investigation showed allegations of
improper conduct with an employee and
still no word yet from the president in
response continues bianna thank you